Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Monday
morning podcast from Monday, April 15th.
Ouch. 2019. How you guys doing today?
On this fucking tax day? Ah. Oh,
Uncle Sam's knocking at your
door. Uncle Sam. He's a whore.
He's taken all your fucking
money unless you didn't do shit.
And then he gives you some, I didn't
do anything this year. Uncle Sam. Oh,
they're there. Here's some money for
you. Pay Uncle Sam. I work my balls off.
I'll take that.
Um, anyways, I hope today fine.
She wanted the fun side of tax day. I
hope it does. I hope it does. You know,
it's funny as I actually found
a fucking w nine or whatever,
you have to go give to my accountant.
It's the 15th, and he's going to be like,
well where the fuck was this?
Went back and I was asking,
where are you parking derby
fucking nines where, man, my,
my lawyer is a, he's a
southern character. Um,
my lawyer, my accountant. How are
you guys? How are you this morning?
I'm actually,
I'm mute.
You see how I didn't even wait to see
how you're doing because I don't care how
it's all about me on this podcast.
It's why I don't have guests. Um,
oh,
freckles is fucking white out.
MMM.
This is the thing about
being a fucking redhead.
Even when the red party you had is gone,
right?
MMM.
There's only so much sun that someone
like myself can take on during a 48 hour
period.
Uh,
really only an eight hour period or I am
going to be in series fucking problems
here and I'm old freckle,
spent the entire weekend out in the sun
on Saturday. I went to Long Beach
and I went down there and I,
I watched uh, the Long Beach, uh, GP,
the Grand Prix down there,
whatever the hell they call is fucking
amazing because not only was there a
couple of races,
there was also like people out there
trying to qualify for the Indy 500 or
something.
I didn't get that part.
Well maybe they will get like
qualifying to try and qualify.
I don't know how the fuck it works,
but it was kind of reminded me
of like a mini Lamont where, uh,
you got all these different classes of
cars that were out there racing. Um,
and uh, it was so fucking cool
and I got to go down and you know,
go in the whole pit area would have
the fuck they call it the paddock.
Um,
and they had BMWs and
Porsche's and Corvettes and
then they had more indie indie
car racing style cars.
And I got hooked up by a good buddy
of mine and he got this one pass,
it said to take a hot lap, which really
sounds, but you get no fucking race car.
And the guy tears around the track at
about 120, a hundred, 230 miles an hour.
Now I had already done
something like that. Um,
at the, uh, the Indy 500, that time when,
when for with for all things, comedy,
comedy,
comedy.
I interviewed Danica Patrick right before
her last race and she took me around
in a Camaro.
So I already did that.
And my lovely wife was the one who kind
of put together the whole long beach
thing. So, and I knew that
she was bored shitless,
so I was like, um, can you,
can my wife go instead of me? And
the guy was like, yeah, I mean,
if that's what you want, it's like, yeah,
man, I've already done this. I, you know,
I gotta, I gotta keep her
adrenaline going here. And, uh,
she ended up jumping in this car
and she gets some fucking Porsche,
which I guess was worth like fucking
300 grand and this guy tool around the
track, she did a little Instagram
thing about it, but, um,
that put a big smile on her
face and got to go. And again,
I don't know who she drove with, but, uh,
she thought he was dead. That was his job.
That that's what the fuck he did.
And it turned out he was like some like
legendary racecar driver who would want
a ton of racist or something.
Um,
but anyways,
uh,
we end up having a great
fucking time and a dude that I,
I've been meaning to go to that,
that is a killer fucking event.
The crowd is like crazy intuitive.
And on the first lap of the
first race that I saw, um,
there was a, there was an accident when
you just heard the cry go, ah, you know,
freaking out cause they fucking, we'll
watch it and up on the TV. And, uh,
there's a couple of hotels down there too,
for those of you who don't want to sit
in the sun like me that have balconies
that overlooked the race track.
So it's like basically, you know,
you get high enough up a floor,
it's like you're hovering in a fucking
helicopter just watching the whole
frigging race and then he can have
the TV on in your living room,
you know what I mean?
And then he could burn some call and
do a couple other things to fuck up the
atmosphere just for your own fucking
personal enjoyment. It was tremendous.
I had a moment there where I was almost
going to get to meet Bobby Rail. Um,
who is far as I know is I think the
first guy who ever won a NASCAR event and
then won the Indy 500.
Um, that's quite a leap.
I don't that you didn't see
a lot back then. You know,
Dale Buche good old boys back in the day.
Hell,
they would just run some car they had
Shannon had fucking weekend before.
It was much more like that. I caught
the tail end, you know, when bought it.
Baker Cale Yarborough Harry Gant, you
know, here and gaining a scold Bain,
it, your Buick, regal, whatever.
The fuck it when this is when the fucking
car is still looked like something
you'd drive down the street.
I caught the tail end of that.
Darrell Waltrip, Bobby
Bonia. No, I'm sorry.
That's a baseball players
and um, well the fuck
else was out there. Oh,
Bill Elliot,
the Bill Burr is fucking star car drivers.
You know.
[inaudible] he said, I looked like
Ron Howard. It's like, no, I didn't.
I used to look like I used to look
like Bill Elliot Aka Dollar Bill.
MMM.
Which was never my neck.
Okay.
Um, what the fuck am I talking about? I'm
wiped out. Sorry. And then Sunday, um,
when all this unbelievable sports
shit was happening when tiger woods
one the mat,
oh my God,
that was a scary moment.
All of a sudden my mixer wasn't
working and I was like, Holy Shit.
I believe I just said, oh no. I'm
like, now what the fuck am I gonna do?
How am I ever going to go out and buy
another $60 fucking two channel mixer?
It's $99.
It gets has center.
MMM.
Turns out it's just the
outlet in my house. All right.
Okay.
I love it. I love buying an old house with
character. It's got a lot of character,
you know.
See that guy over there. He
doesn't work at all. He's got,
he's got a lot of character. Um,
he doesn't have a fucking job.
That guy has a lot of character.
It's weird how like the way human beings,
you're not judged having a lot of
character if you don't have a fucking job.
But you know, if a house
doesn't work at all, it's,
that's how it's described
getting a lot of character.
It's going to Kuwait
personality. Um, anyways,
tiger woods won the master.
Ah,
ladies, uh, the ladies all these years,
they were hoping that that
motherfucker would never win again.
So there's stupid fucking
theory that, you know, you know,
women always try to take the
credit when, um, when a great
man does something,
whenever a great man achieves something,
what do they try to fucking do? They go,
well these teas, white supported them.
So when she fucking leaves him,
when the guy's old and he's limping around
and all that and he can't hit a jump
shot anymore and she goes out
and takes his fucking house,
they always try to say,
well she gave up on her
dreams to follow her. Yeah.
Cause her dreams couldn't
sell out an arena.
Here's one for you ladies.
I don't know why I'm coming at you like,
because it's fun. You know what? It's fun.
You guys are just getting your
fucking asses kicked by all these man.
China's out there right now
sitting there fucking interview.
When you specifically white women,
like you have difficult lives,
which is just fucking hilarious to me.
MMM.
But it also is the genius a
woman, you know what I mean? The,
the manipulating powers of
women is to such a high level,
their skill and manipulation is such to
a high level that literally white women
are being interviewed
on television right now.
Like there's some sort
of like oppressed people
both.
Um, what is it like to be a white
woman in the United States of America?
That has to be so difficult.
You have no idea. Every Jay,
when I wake up and I look
at my SUV and I'm like, oh,
it needs to be vacuumed out.
Um,
okay.
Anyways, there's that big fucking
stupid fucking argument about support.
Whenever somebody great specifically a
man does something great and then a woman
cleans them out or this credit, you
know, or the guys given a fucking speech,
he always has to thank his fucking wife.
You know what I mean? And you know,
all guys, we know what this
is, say her fucking name.
So she's in a good mood on the car ride
home because God knows her emotions come
first before anything else
in the fucking relationships.
So that's why guys are given a shout out.
But what women do is they
take it at face value,
like they actually had
something to fucking deal with
it. You know what I mean?
Ladies, let me ask you this
fucking question. Okay.
Because for all these fucking years,
they had this theory that when
tigers personal life fell apart.
That's why his golf game fell apart,
which was complete horse shit. All right.
If you read any of those stories,
the men definitely had the
ability to compartmentalize it
life.
That wasn't the issue from day
one when he was just a kid.
What do you want his first master
master master, right? When?
When that fucking 1997
all these fucking old white guys who are
going like, this guy is unbelievable.
He's gonna fucking do this and that.
But I'll tell you the way he swings,
it's such a violent swing. I'm worried
about his back and his knees and all that.
They called it.
Okay.
A lot of them are probably hoping it
was going to happen because they want to
Jack Nicholson or Nicholas,
sorry to still be at the top.
You know who's kidding?
Who Golf isn't exactly the most inclusive
fucking sport out there, right? So are,
I don't know, personal, uh,
Cutler and like they said,
person of Color Breighton fucking
lick cold sucks this Sun God.
Jack Nicholas.
So they were predicting that his,
his,
his body was going to break
down and give out on him,
which it did right when
his personal life did.
So of course everybody gives the Barbie
doll all this fucking credit debts.
She was his rock.
She did did that fuck Outta here.
The guy did it on him by himself.
That's it. He did it on his own.
At the end of the fucking day,
she's not out there swinging the fucking
yard sticker. Right. You know, in,
for any women who don't like that
shit. Let me ask you this, okay.
When a woman gives birth and a guy
sitting there supporting her are going,
come on, you do it. Okay. Okay. Who?
Who deserves the lion's share of the
credit when the baby gets delivered.
Furthermore, who gets the lion's share
of the crest? The woman still does.
You know what I mean?
But you can better believe if we were
pushing a kid out of our ass there and the
woman was chairing this
on, you know, God knows,
God knows the court system would be like,
well, he had al, she played a major role.
Okay,
I'll come fans for the patriots,
haven't gotten their own super bowl
rings for supporting the Patriots through
this incredible super bowl run
with my ring.
I supported you Tom Brady.
So anyway,
I'm just,
I'm really talking to go small
segment of fucking women out there,
but it's fun to fucking trash them.
Um,
I missed the whole fucking thing.
I didn't see any of it.
And I was at,
I was at Fort Irwin out in the Moh
Javi desert there in the Mojave desert
watching the army plays some war games.
Don't ask me how the fuck this
whole thing came together. I did,
if I did a show at an American
Legion is a comic there.
John Sites who,
who is a veteran himself and you just
go down there and you're smoking cigars
with veterans and they asked you
shit and you just keep saying yes.
And next thing you know as a
bald, redheaded mail, you were,
you were out in the middle
of the fucking Mojave desert,
no piss this being out there
fucking in the middle of the guide where
we actually, we got up at like five 30.
Well you had to be there at five 30
in the morning. It was pretty cool.
We flew like a Vietnam era. Uh, Huey,
like the apocalypse now on, you know,
Charlie doesn't like to surf, you know,
we flew that thing up out there.
Uh,
I got to sit in a Black
Hawk and an Apache,
talked to all these pilots and then
I watched a fucking war game and um,
eight,
the fucking military meal that they have
out there that you cut it open with a
knife and there's some fucking
psycho thing that you, I don't know,
you kind of rub it together and then
you stick the Chili in and it heats up.
I got to tell you, it was pretty
fucking good. All right. Granted,
I wouldn't want to eat that.
Every God damn day for two fucking
years in the middle of God knows where.
I wouldn't want to do that. But
you know, for one day it was funny.
I'm so Hollywood, they were like,
you know what's funny is this,
this meal here is actually 5,000 calories
because these guys had just fucking
sitting out there. These brave men and
women are sitting out there, right?
They pretend days, they're
out there. So then, you know,
they're burning all these calories
and shit. And I'm immediately,
I'm so Hollywood,
like 5,000 calories,
I have an acting gig coming up
and I can only eat about 1875.
That's my target.
But I ate the whole fucking thing.
I didn't want to disrespect anybody.
So anyways,
watch these whole fucking war games.
And it was, it was fascinating.
They like play,
it's almost like laser tag and they get
like these blinking lights on like tanks
and shit like that. And, uh, if
you get hit and it blinks twice,
it's considered not a direct
hit, but you're, you're, I
don't know, sort of wounded.
And if it blinks four times, that means
you're dead. You're out of the game,
you'll hold tank shuts down, you're
not able to communicate with anybody.
Cause you know,
they were radically you fucking dead.
And I just watched how the a black horse,
the home team they drew in,
the other two was basically an
away game for the other people.
And uh, I kind of at the end of
the day learned a lot of shit.
I don't know a lot of shit,
but I learned a lot of shit.
Like how that terrain is fondant
and it's basically you
move through the valleys,
you're not going to try to go up and
over. Certainly with all that, you know,
equipment, which isn't something that
I ever really even thought about.
So you just Kinda know, all
right, where can they come from?
And then they just basically draw them in.
You know,
it's, it's like, Hey,
look at this over here.
And they go after that and then they get,
I don't know what the proper terminology,
they get flanked.
I don't know what the fuck it
is. They, they hit him from
the other side like, Hey,
look at my left hand.
And then they punch him with the right
was essentially what they kept doing.
And it was working. It kept drawing
people in like you'd see them,
they'd spot their position,
the other team would get excited and they
would just fucking come flying in guns
a blazing and then they
would just get broadsided.
And by the time they figured out where
the fire was coming from, it was over.
If they were fucked,
um,
I got to go in an old tank and I shot a,
uh,
whether you know that gun on
top of the Turret Terrick I,
whenever the fuck it is,
that little thing.
And you know what I realized in that
moment, I could give a shit about guns.
I am all about aviation. I was
hanging on every word of those pilots,
asking them how, you know,
the whole thing worked.
Why the tail rotor was that
much higher than the main road.
I could've talked about that all day long,
but fucking sitting there,
my ears a shot. I don't want
to see, you know, it was like
doing that,
you know,
something every fucking redneck
would get half a woody to go do.
And I was up there, I felt guilty. I
was just up to like cheese. It's Christ.
How many bullets are left.
My ears are ringing. FOC.
Um, I was more fascinated with how you
change the fucking, if, if one of the,
uh,
the tracks comes off the tank,
how you change the fucking thing and
what a bitch it is to change and how long
it takes and how fucking
pissed off everybody gets.
I was more fascinated with
that. Um, although they'll,
the fucking weaponry on the, uh, the
Apache was pretty cool. You know,
that thing that thing's on the
side where it's just like they,
it's like a circle thing and like
they just kind of all his comes out.
And one of the pilots was saying,
yeah,
those things are about as
accurate as a bottle rocket.
So it's really like this big skill to
try and to initially try to get some sort
of accuracy with those things.
But anyways, we spent like, um,
okay
God, we get out there at like
seven something in the morning.
Yeah.
And uh,
I took pictures with a lot of the
troops out there and as you notice,
it's fucking hilarious.
I kept it real.
I came out there and
dress like a civilian.
I wasn't going to go to the army
navy store like a friend of mine did,
but he was a veteran and buy
some fucking camouflage pants.
I walked out ahead like
this mccoley vans on.
I didn't realize we were going out
in the middle of the desert. I,
this is fucking windbreaker that
my wife bought me for Christmas.
I've only worn it like five times. I don't
know how I'm going to get it clean. Um,
but I want to thank everybody out there.
Fort Irwin.
I'm definitely going to come back and do
a show if I can figure out where to do
one. I didn't see where they had any
sort of a theater or a stage or anything,
but I definitely, I was talking
to John Sites that I go do it,
we gotta come back out and do a
show and these people are great. Um,
okay.
They treated us awesome.
And uh, I dunno, that was,
that was quite a goddamn experience.
Like if I was gonna miss the
Masters and see tiger when,
cause I know I can watch that on online,
I'll be able to find it.
But I heard it was the
most exciting masters since
Nicholas Nicholas and 86. But,
um, I don't know. It was amazing.
And what was Keller was every fucking
mmm
army guy, a woman that even
remotely knew who I was, said,
hey, I love Apis for family. Not one
of them said anything about my standup,
which was so fucking cool.
So I'm kind of feeling like after three
seasons episodes, episode, family,
it's finally breaking throat. Um, anyway,
so thank you to everybody out
there. Fort Irwin, I want to come
back out and do a show.
All right.
Not In the middle of the fucking desert.
I need a stage and an air
condition bunker. You give
me that and I'll, I'll be,
I'll be back out there. Other
than that, I'm, maybe I'll, I'll,
I'll go out there in the winter time.
I'll do a nighttime show when all
them creepy critters come out.
I guess there's some turtle out there too.
That's like in danger.
Okay.
So if they come upon it,
they supposed to let people know and
then they come out and they remove it and
they stick it somewhere else. And uh, the
big joke is the reason why is in danger,
just because if you come up
and you try and pick it up,
it's defense mechanism is it empties
all the fluids out of itself,
bodily fluids, and then it like, it dies
of dehydration immediately. It's like,
well, I mean, if that's
your, if your defense is to
essentially kill yourself, um,
I don't know how long you can be around.
I would,
I wouldn't assume that that
would be something you could
do. All right. Anyways,
um, congratulations to tiger woods. I,
when I got off you,
when I came back to, uh,
yeah,
you know, the helicopter, we were going to
fly back. I turned my phone back on and,
uh,
you know,
I got all these messages from Versium
Bartolik and all these guys flipping out
about tiger. I was like, oh my God,
you gotta be kidding me. And, uh,
so I immediately looked up tiger woods
and I saw that picture of him when he's
sunk, the sank the puck, the
pot sink, the Putt. And, um,
I can't remember the last time
I was at happy for an athlete.
CanNot fucking remember. So fucking
great. And now he's got like, what,
15 or 16 and Jack has 18 if he had 43,
puts it all back together.
I mean,
Jack One one in 86,
he was 46 years old,
so he can definitely do it. But
I thought, I remember seeing him,
I watched the beginning of
the masters and I saw him.
He looked like he was in
really good shape. Um,
uh, that's just, I mean,
how great is that for golf?
I can't imagine what the fucking ratings
were and any amount of jackasses who
are now going to go take up the game.
That guy has been the greatest thing
for golf, you know, of the last,
you know, quarter century. Like he's
basically had the sport on his back.
Um, so it's so great to
see that guy come back. Uh,
congratulations tiger woods
and congratulations to
yard Boston Bruins tying up
to series. They may pull a
first the Boston Bruins out day.
It's a tale of two different gates.
This is my takeaway from both games.
I would say in game one,
the Bruins got lulled into the maple
leaf's game up and down the end to end
fucking defenseman getting caught up ice,
whatever the fuck they were doing.
We let up,
like I felt like six breakaways.
They'd a break away gold and then they
scored on a penalty shot. It's just like,
what the fuck is, this isn't how
we play. And then in gained two,
I thought the maple leafs got drawn
into the Bruins, a physical play.
And, you know, I thought on both games,
both like the Bruins lost their composure
in the first game and I thought the
leads kind of lost their composure
in the second game is far as like not
sticking to their game plan
and getting drawn into,
it's like watching a boxing match and a
boxer gets drawn into the center of the
ring for a broth,
you know,
cause the other guy kind of gets
them into that macho fucking mode.
So game three I would assume is tonight.
Like I said,
I was kind of off the grid this
weekend. And um, by the way,
I'm going to look it up right now.
What the fuck is happening down in Tampa?
That is the only fucking time after
game two when Columbus beat, uh,
beat the lightning as the only time
I've ever seen was it total rally.
That's the only time I've seen
that guy smile like that. Like he,
he looked elated.
Oh my God,
they fucking lost again.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I mean,
it's fucking over.
I was just gonna say Columbus has to win
game three because you can't wake the
sleeping giant. That is the Tampa
Bay lightning. Good fucking Lord.
I got to watch she NHL network.
What is,
what are the Columbus blue jackets doing
that the Bruins couldn't fucking do
play off shock. Columbus wins
again. Goes up three nothing.
Okay, here's some quotes. Everyone's
got to step up. Everyone's got a place,
solid solid game and we've got
to make it a little bit harder.
That was Tyler Johnson.
Okay.
I Dunno who that is. I don't know
who anybody is. I got a kid now.
I don't know who fucking plays
for who. All right. Game three.
Steven Stamkos now I believe
he's still playing with Tampa.
Uh, he said they have no power.
Plays in a game is pretty surprising.
The after earn those and I thought
we played well in the third,
but it's no constellation right now with
the position we're in sorta complaining,
but not really.
Our focus has to be coming out
and playing with that same pace,
the same execution, that same desperation
right from the start play one period.
At a time said Ryan McMahon. I don't know
who the fuck any of these people are.
MMM.
Somebody asked a question, when was the
last time Tampa went to Stanley clap? Why?
That would be 2004
okay.
That would be 2004 um,
Jesus Christ,
you know,
I went to a game out there in Columbus
and I was very impressed with their fans
and that was early on. They were all
in, they were injured the fucking game.
So congratulations to them. Tampa Bay
lightning fans. Fuck, I've been there.
God knows I,
I've been there.
I've been there as a fan where you fucking
kick the shit and left my first year
of watching the Boston Bruins,
like really letting all my
first year I went to a game.
Okay.
Was that 83 season?
80 was it 83 84 we won the
president's trophy or something.
We had Pete Peters and he was like the
best goalie in the league and all of that.
And the first round was
best three out of five.
And the Canadians came in and they were
like fourth place in the Adams Division
and we drew them and those fucking
assholes came in and swept us like they
always did back then.
And uh,
the first game that was the first
Boston Bruins game I ever went to,
mmm.
I was taking French and the French kids
had come over and they took him to a
game and you had to buy the
tickets through. Our French
teacher was pretty cool.
And we all went down to
the old Boston Garden.
And I remember we went in there and we
were sitting with the French kids and it
took me about eight seconds to realize
that those fucking assholes started
rooting for the Canadians because,
uh,
they are started hearing all that blue
block, a rouge and all that fucking,
which is so fucking ridiculous because
the French don't even respect the fucking
French Canadians. They don't consider them
real French. They consider him farmers.
Um, but I got to hand it to those French
kids. They will fucking wave in these,
these Montreal Canadian flags right in
the faces of these drunk fucking Bruins
fans in the upper deck.
But I think because they were French and
they just want an American jerk offs,
they somehow got away with it.
But I remember my French
treats her teacher looking
over at me like making this
face like, did these fucking
kids know what they're doing?
This is getting pretty
intense. Um, oh my God.
Would that been hilarious if a brawl
broke out and the next day we went to
fucking French class?
You know,
it'd be hilarious is nothing would
happen as far as like back then where now
that would be like a national news story.
Like what was that
French teacher thinking?
Bringing these poor immigrants
down to that hostile environment.
Look at this cell phone footage
that wouldn't have happened.
Do you realize I grew up in an era where
something like that could have happened
and know the people in this section would
not even have known the backstory of
what went down. They would have thought
it was just a bunch of fucking cons.
Who came down from Montreal
and got their asses kicked.
They wouldn't realize now that
was like teenagers from France.
Um, anyway, uh,
so game three, I imagine it's tonight
a huge fucking game. Huge game.
We got to take control of
the goddamn series. Uh,
Toronto is such a good team and I was
not believing in their goaltender there
then Anderson guy.
And um,
basically I watched one game and he
mishandled the puck twice. So I was like,
I know about hockey, but he's been playing
great. Certainly in that first game,
that first game we had,
like I felt like we had 20 more shots
than leased it and they still came into
one. So leaps have a really good
team and I really liked the least,
you know what I mean? Um, always have. Um,
so like I said, if we don't beat
the least in this series, uh,
that they're going to be the team
that I'm going to be rooting for. Um,
although Columbus, I
mean, that's a fun story.
Now if they'd be Tampa
Cheese is Christ and I've,
I haven't seen a second of that series.
I'm missing the whole frigging thing.
I'm running around like a
lunatic. Why? Why is that?
Cause we got the last episode of
F is for family for season four.
We're writing it this week.
Uh,
but what happens at this time of the
season is as you're writing the episode,
you're also getting the first animatics,
which is the first rough drawings.
And then you have to go back and punch
that stuff up and look at the edits.
So it starts to become like a, rather
than one giant wave writing the script,
it starts becoming a series of
waves hitting the beach. And uh, oh,
freckles gets busy here. But, uh,
I definitely to tune in to
watch that game for, um,
that Columbus series and uh,
and of course I'm going to be watching my
Bruins tonight. All right. What else? Oh,
big announcement. This is something
I've been trying to do for awhile. Um,
I have a charity show coming up, um, on,
uh, August 1st at the Wilbur
Boston, Massachusetts.
Yours truly is going to be there with
a bunch of other, uh, Boston comics.
It's for the, uh, the
Travis Roy Foundation.
It's laughing with your buddies
for the Travis Roy Foundation.
Travis Roy of course,
was a great hockey player for the
Boston Bruins and unfortunately, um,
and you know, he broke his neck and
got paralyzed plane for the team.
And um, I remember where I
was when I saw that story.
That story really affected
everybody living in Boston.
And um,
I was,
I've been trying to get involved with
their charity for a long time and it's
finally going to happen. And um, this
is basically, yeah, the, the, you know,
this the most important show I'm
doing one of the year, man, this is a,
this is a huge thing to be able to,
uh,
do something for the Travis Roy Foundation
has been able to email back and forth
with him. He's a great dude,
obviously, uh, with a great heart,
super positive and he's doing such great
things for people who are in a similar
situation as him. It's going to be
August 1st at, uh, at the Wilbur theater.
The venue,
presale is Wednesday and Thursday.
Tickets are on sale Friday.
Uh,
www.thewilburwilbur.com/artist/bill
burr bill dashboard,
another backslash Jesus Christ. Why don't
we just fucking tweet the Goddamn link?
I think that that's where we are.
What we're going to do.
I can't wait to do that show. Um, oh,
freckles is going to have a fun summer.
I got a a got an acting gig and uh,
that shoots back on the east coast.
Um,
some of you saw my general
hospital trailer to,
well that's a first soap opera
actually released a trailer.
But I like to think I did such a good
job on general hospital that they want to
hide my, my three episode arc.
It's actually just one episode. Um,
all right. And then new to all
things comedy, check this out.
All things comedy going
international here. All right.
This is the copy to all my
mandarin speaking listeners,
which I hope there's some,
the mandarin dream podcasts with thing.
Chow funk Chow. They'd said
it wrong. That fun. Chow,
a Beijing born Los Angeles comedian.
I met him the other night
at the comedy store.
He talks about his experience growing
up in a culture that didn't worship
American comedy,
to being right in the middle of it as
a comedy store employee and standup
comedian. Um, it's available
on iTunes, Spotify,
Google play and youtube.
And this podcast is basically,
it's in Mandarin and in English. And, uh,
we're very excited that he's come on board
here at all things comedy and open us
up to,
I don't know,
a billion possible new
listeners over in China.
So what's up to everybody?
Mainland China,
welcome to all things comedy.
I hope you enjoy his podcast.
MMM. If he can find a way to listen
to it because I'm not sure, you know,
I know they black out the fucking
internet over there. From what I've heard,
as far as the American propaganda done,
told me, I don't know if it's true or not.
Um,
all right,
let's read some of some of the
advertising here for the week.
Uh, for him, I ask you,
do you want a bald spot to pop up
on your hairline? But, oh, sorry.
Do you want a bald spot?
The pop up or your hairline to recede?
Hey or do you want to do
something about it first?
Why did guys turned a weird solutions?
Because they don't want to go bald or
do nothing because they dealt with it.
They accepted it. That's how I
dealt with balding. I fucking,
I acted like that fucking
turtle out in the Mojave desert.
I just fucking rolled over
and died. Um, anyways,
when they can turn to
medicine and science, this
really is like a thing, like,
I guess you don't have to go bald anymore.
It's funny.
The other guy I was working with was
also bald and we were talking about, um,
he was going to you getting those old
age spots on top of your head. I said,
no fucking way, dude, I do not have
my bald head in the sun whatsoever.
And he goes, yeah, man, it sucks. And then
we just started laughing. I go, you know,
it's fucking crazy with all
these stem cell research,
they can literally grow a fucking ear
and a god Damn Petri dish and they can't
come up with, um, a solution to balding.
And, uh, and we were both laughing
about it. I go, yeah, but you know,
it's fucking funny.
Once she shaved her head like I
don't think I would want to go back.
There is something great. If you shave
your head, you're always ready to go.
Oh, you got to do is throw on a shirt with
the F that's fucking iron and you look
like, I don't know, you had a spot. Um,
this is probably not shift to
be saying in a solution for bar.
Don't end up like me talking to another
bald guy in a parking lot after being in
a desert all day,
acting like you like looking like a
fucking poor man's Yule Brenner. Okay.
Anyways, no more war. No more. Anyways,
for hims.com is a one shop for hair loss,
skincare,
sexual wellness for men.
This is basically,
this is just putting the entire
male ego back together. Okay?
Okay. They're going to give
you a lion's mane. A hair.
They're going to clear up your skin.
Your Dick is going to be standing up at
attention. What the fuck, Morty,
you need no more awkward in person doctor
visits or long form pharmacy lines.
Oh,
that's the worst.
I went to a couple of those when I was
considering trying to do something about
my situation.
And you just sit in the
waiting room looking at another
fucking bald in guys and
you're trying not to make fucking
icontact for hymns connects you to real
doctors online,
which could save you hours completely
confidential and discreet online. Um,
answer a few questions. A doctor will
review and they determine if, uh,
if it's right for you,
uh,
can prescribe you medication to treat
the hair loss that is shipped directly to
your door. Get the hair loss treatment.
Everyone is talking about featured in Gq,
men's health,
Esquire and playboy to name a few.
My listeners can get started with the
hims complete hair kit for just $5 right
now while supplies last and
subject to doctor approval.
See website for full details
and safety information.
This could cost hundreds if you went to
the doctor or a pharmacy somewhere else,
go to four hymns,
a h I m s.com/berm.
That's for h I m s.com/birth for
hims.com/ [inaudible] all right.
Only one other read guys.
Lastly, but not leastly, uh,
better help.
Um,
is there something that interferes with
your happiness or is preventing you from,
from achieving your
goals? If so, better help.
Online counseling is there for you.
Better help offers licensed professional
professional counselors who are
specialized in issues such as depression,
stress,
anxiety, relationships, uh,
sleeping, trauma, anger,
family conflicts,
LGBT matters.
Um, grief, self esteem,
Jesus Christ and more.
Seems like a long list.
Shorten as needed.
It says in parentheses.
Why are you guys fucking kind of
doing everything over there? Um,
Sasquatch shape, shifter,
whatever your fucking problem is.
A connect with your
professional counselor in,
in a safe and private online environment.
Anything you share is confidential
online and it's so convenient.
People, okay. Both of these things
are great for hymns and better help.
Nothing is confidential online.
It's confidential until somebody
fucking shares it or get you,
you get your fucking site hacked.
All right.
Online security is, is
the this decades the, uh,
the check's in the mail. All right?
You can now get your own help.
You can get your own time
at your own pace. Well,
you can get help at your own time,
at your own pace.
You can schedule a secure video or phone
sessions plus chat and text with your
therapist.
If you're not happy.
If you not happy with your counselor,
you can request a new one in anytime.
No additional charge. Best of all,
it's a truly affordable option.
And for my listeners,
get 10% off your first month
and discount code burst.
So why not get started today?
Go to better health.com/bird simply fill
out a questionnaire to help them assess
your needs and get matched with a
counselor you'll love better help.com/bar
oh,
all right. What else did I want to talk
about? Was there anything else? Uh,
Lewis Hamilton, once again, finally had
his first right, great start of the year.
Blew right by foul Terry Botox who had
the pull position and that was pretty
much it.
And I had been watching racing f one race
in long enough to know that will Lewis
Hamilton gets to first in that first
turn, the fucking race is over, it's over.
And I also know that if he's in second
or third place and there's only 10 laps
to go and he has no chance of winning the
race, he's going to start complaining.
I don't understand why other people
aren't helping me out here. Um,
I was really hoping Botox was
going to win that because, uh,
I didn't realize the
first year when I watched,
mmm,
what a great fucking year that was.
To Watch two drivers on the same team
compete for it and not help each other and
smash into each other. What the fuck
was that guy's name? The guy retired.
I can't remember his name.
Anyway,
plowing ahead.
I did not see the moto GP race.
I have a lot of shit to get caught up on
it because I was out in the desert. Um,
I was being such a fucking
asshole when I was out there too.
Like they were explaining
all this military stuff to
me and I was just standing
there in my fucking vans and my, my, uh,
Pete Carroll Khakis and they would explain
all this military shit and then when
they would just be like, do you have
any questions? And I was just like, um,
kit, I bet the stars at night
are incredible out here.
Can you see the stars a lot better
than you came without the thing in the
fucking those the guy when special
forces and he totally rolled with it.
He was like, absolutely, it makes
you question your existence.
We're just a speck of dust.
Um,
yeah, there was a lot of
ball break it out there.
And it reminded me of back in the day
when I used to work in a warehouse and all
we did was just give each other shit
all day was the most fun fucking thing.
Yeah.
Ever. And uh, at some point,
because one of the guys on special
forces was also had a kid around my age.
We both started going off on that show,
fancy Nancy
and uh,
and what an asshole she is. And how we
both, uh, watching her going like this,
I don't want my daughter
watching this shit.
Okay.
And we watch
it.
Oh cause she's fancy.
She's totally into like status and who
were friends aren't having tree forts and
not letting people in and is trying
to fill up her life with like fucking
clothes and shit.
Like that's going to fill up our
passion and we would just trashing it,
laughing our asses off.
And at some point we said that the working
title of that for the working title
of it was actually Conti Kathy, but they
couldn't get it on the air or something.
Like I forget.
But we just fucking sitting there in the
middle of this desert just laughing our
balls off about this fucking cartoon.
And then all of a sudden this
war games thinks started and um,
I don't know. I want to thank everybody
once again, it was out there, man.
That was a hell of an experience that
I will definitely not forget. Um,
okay.
So anyway, let's see. Let's read some
of the questions here for this week.
All right.
Uh,
okay. So I sent out a tweet
as a joke saying, you know,
I wish somebody from England,
okay.
Could explain to me the
different leagues in soccer.
And I was doing that as a joke because
last week when I fucking thought that Man
City had launched a league game
and that what's his face is,
you know, it's so fucking stupid.
It's not a fucking league game,
but they still add the points or don't
have the points. I don't fucking get it.
It's so fucking ridiculous.
Like this is just a friendly,
the middle of the season. Let's just
play a fucking game for the fuck of it.
And then there's the
champion's league anyway,
so I have all these fucking English
cunts put down their fish and chips for a
fucking minute.
Right then waddled they're bloated upper
bodies with these skinny fucking legs
over to their computer and just started.
It was hilarious.
They were fucking live at, at me. Um,
and so I was just sort
of being a dick going,
I wish somebody would explain it to me.
So may if I could see if I could get him
to start writing and capital letters.
But what ended up happening was because
I wrote it nicely rather than being a
dick here, sorry, still going
fucking sand in my throat. Um,
yeah.
Uh, they actually sent me a bunch of
emails to try to explain it to me.
So now I can't break that balls anymore.
So all right. So here's the deal.
This is basically explaining
all the different league.
Soccer has has a playoff,
but it's called the champion's league.
The top four premier league teams at
the end of the season make the playoffs.
Just like the divisions in American
sports. See, I didn't know this.
I'm the team with the most points in
the premier league basically wins the
president's trophy.
The biggest difference is that the
playoffs happen at the same time as the
regular season.
I see like that I needed
more explanation there.
So that basically means that
this season is a play. All right,
so the Tottenham win over man
city happened in the playoffs.
What?
Liverpool is currently
in the playoffs and there are no
tie games. If you get a chance,
watch the Champions League.
It's really awesome to watch.
Thanks and go fuck yourself.
Yeah, no, see I would watch that.
Now why didn't somebody just
tell me that from the beginning,
but the Champions League is also,
it's not just the top four teams.
I thought there was something
like with like Switzerland,
I dunno,
I'm just going to keep asking questions
to like get it because now that seems,
that seems exciting to me as
opposed to just, you know what,
we met twice during the regular
season and I lost both fucking gains,
but I still have more points to you.
So I win the premier league. I don't,
I don't know. Anyways, um,
this is Biden,
dear Billy night night shades.
I'm not offended by your take on Biden
cause I don't really get offended and I'm
not outraged by, by Biden. Okay,
so now you know immediately this
person's going to fucking be offended.
My opinion, however, is
different than yours,
which despite what they tell us
on the new, the news is, okay.
All right.
I would take another look at the video
of him groping side Boob in shit.
If that was a guy I work with,
I'd have the same opinion.
And it happens when the guy is next
to a podium, not on the dance floor,
sending signals. Some of the
girls are young. It's just weird.
And I'm not even saying
he's got bad intentions.
You just can't touch strangers that long.
Ha Ha. And I totally understand the,
it was from a different time thing,
but my dad never rubbed up on people and
he served in Korea in drove a cutlass,
love you and love the podcast. Oh, here's
the thing about the Joe Biden thing.
I didn't even see that. I saw like half
a cliff before I went out on Conan.
They go, you want to talk about
that? A Gal fucking talk about it.
I don't pay attention to shit.
I'm just so fucking sick of everybody
having their fucking career ended on,
on, on our fucking, you know,
a two minute tripping
penalty and everybody else
sitting there fucking acting
like they're good people.
As I've said from day one,
if everybody's fucking text
messages were made public,
could anybody go to work next Monday?
Nobody.
Nobody could.
So everybody's got to stop fucking lick
this fucking witch hunt that like you
know for your own fucking instance.
The thing too,
the amount of people that are going to
watch Biden's dream of becoming president
get destroyed just for the
entertainment purpose of it.
That's all they want to do.
And there's another thing too,
is because there's so many different
ways to just sit down and watch shit,
there's so much shit to fucking watch.
There's so much weight,
so many ways to watch shit.
That one ratings grabbing his
fucking stirring up controversy.
Jesus Christ.
Do you remember the fucking family feud?
Richard Dawson was like tongue kissing
every fucking chick on the God damn
fucking thing.
There was no fucking problem.
He hosted few bap bap, bap, bap,
bap, bap, bap, bap, bap. Right?
It was fine.
Yeah.
Everybody fucking sitting there getting
uncomfortable. It didn't happen to you.
Nothing happened to you.
This isn't your fucking story.
If the woman's uncomfortable,
she should say something.
Jesus fucking Christ.
Tell your mother that shit where
it's just like so and so said this,
but did they really need that?
Should Peyton manning be upset while
he's obviously not upset? Espn,
I remember that one from back
in the day. I don't know. I'm,
I'm one of these fucking people there.
It's just like if the,
that's between the
fucking people involved.
I don't know what they're
fucking relationship is and
neither do you for all you
know,
he was maybe the side boot check.
He's fucking banging and afterwards
she's just like, dude, what the fuck?
Don't grab my Ted on fucking TV.
They're going to know we're fucking
bang and there's a possible scenario.
Look at me with no evidence.
I can do it too.
MMM.
Yeah. I'm not an, I'm not
in the fucking business.
A fucking making up shit and trying to
fucking get people in trouble. Am I?
Maybe I am as a comedian.
I don't know.
I just feel like I'm fucking
joking around and like this,
this fucking thing where you just shove
a microscope up. Everybody's asked.
They're all human.
They're all fucking flawed.
I remember back in the day
when I worked in a warehouse,
there was this fucking manager guy,
he was too fucking touch you. Faley
and you know what?
We all fucking dealt with it.
It was fucking hilarious when he'd get
you and everybody else would just be
laughing at you. But nowadays that
guy would lose his fucking job.
He'd have to be a registered
fucking sex offender.
I remember I used to fucking try
and make sure I was like, you know,
you had to have your head on a
swivel when that guy fucking came in.
Big fucking doughboy looking dude.
Right?
So I was at the vending machine and I was,
uh, I was, I, I've told this story before,
I was trying to figure what the fuck I
was trying to buy some fucking food or
whatever and uh, as you do at a vending
machine. And he came walking in, he goes,
oh, hey bill, how you doing it? As he
was walking by me from left to right,
he slapped
his hand on my left shoulder and then
dragged it across my entire back as,
as he was walking past.
And then squeezed my
right fucking shoulder.
Like it was a perky teddy.
I think he was squeezing
the Sharmane and I was like,
ah.
I mean it took like a decade and a
half to fucking shake that thing off.
Now it should. That guy
had been doing that. No.
Okay.
Do I think I need to report him and he
should fucking then lose his job and then
this is on him for the rest of his
fucking life. Now. He's just weird.
He's a weird guy. Okay. He
didn't fucking dental me,
drug me and throw me in a van.
He fucking, he fucking, yeah.
I don't know how he got
a little too friendly.
Yeah,
he gave me the Heebie.
Jeebies okay.
I don't think giving somebody the Heebie
jeebies should fuck it. End Your career.
I think you ought to be able to sit
down with them and be like, listen,
could you do me a favor?
Can you just say hello?
Okay.
Ninth grader, he was, sorry.
Granted he was my boss
then I was younger and I didn't know
how to fucking say that, but I mean,
you know what? If fucking Jesus
Christ every fucking thing.
Everything is just the biggest thing.
Okay.
Oh,
you know what I did?
I went back into the
warehouse and I fucking told
everybody and I got such a big
laugh telling the story. It was
almost worth the debt. He did it.
The fact that it was worth it. I
don't get, I didn't give a shit.
Okay.
I didn't feel fucking triggered
and all of that fucking crap.
Every fucking thing I know.
But I gotta tell you something right now.
Anybody fought in Korea and drove a
fucking olds cutlass is our right with me.
Um, all right. White
people challenging, uh,
racism.
Hey Mr. Billy Baldwin and I liked it.
That's a new one.
Play on the Baldwin thing. Oh,
what people done that before,
but that's in a different,
different way, right? Anyways, uh,
I'm a fellow mass hole that used to work
in the athletics department at East.
Don't call me a math hall.
It's,
you're shaming an entire state
and I feel like every state,
bring something to the table.
Speaking of which Fort Irwin I learned
when I was there. The square mileage,
square mileage, the
square miles of that, um,
training facility. That base is
bigger than the state of Rhode Island.
How crazy is that? Um, anyways, the class,
where the fuck am I?
Yeah,
I am a fellow mass hall.
They used to work in the
athletics department at a
small college in one of those
rich suburbs of Boston.
Okay.
They ain't all registered there,
buddy.
I wanted to hear your opinion on a
professional development class that I was
forced to go to.
Uh,
the class was titled White People
Challenging Racism to middle aged women.
Ran The class.
One white lady that had to mention
that she had a black husband.
Every other sentence
and the,
and the other,
a black lady who referenced the book
that she wrote every other sentence.
Oh my God, this is like a sketch. I
wish I was there. Long story short.
Okay.
The class was about how the only people
that can be racist in America are white
people because they hold the
power over every minority. Uh,
they're big fanapt. You see
road, their big. Finally,
they're big finale.
Uh,
was showing a video from the 90s of a
high school science teacher showing kids
that all people share the
same DNA and we're one race,
which I mentioned.
Yeah.
They taught me that in middle school
social studies and science class.
I thought everyone knew this.
The black professor also came over to
me and my coworker after we had finished
reviewing and said, you two look
like you don't want to be here.
Okay.
My coworker and I looked at each other
and explain how we had finished the work
she just assigned,
which was to point out how the video
she showed us was racist overall.
It was a very uncomfortable experience
and I was just wondering how you would
have responded in this training.
Sorry for the long email.
Love your stuff and hope you and your
family are well from a fellow mass hall.
All right. Okay. A lot of stuff here.
All right.
The wording of that is so stupid
to say that white people are the only
ones that they have the ability to be
racist is because they
hold the power over other.
Every other minority is such a stupid
fucking way of conveying that thought to a
group of people that you want to
be receptive of that information.
That's immediately going to put every
white person on the defensive and be like,
what the fuck?
And then start sending fucking email
questions to some shitheads podcast who
sits in his basement and talks to himself.
Um,
I would have worded that differently.
I would have said that the reason why
white people being racist is the worst is
because they hold, they do hold the
power over every other minority.
So the effect of them being racist,
um,
is so much more painful.
All right.
And if I was in that class,
what I would have said I would,
I would've said is what you want.
You're saying,
and I'm not saying this is with all white
people because not every white person
is in a position of power,
but overall all the powerful positions,
you know,
99.9% of them sees to be held by
white people. What I would have,
what I would say and what I
have said to people, you know,
when they try to come out with that
white guys are evil shit. It's like,
no they're not.
They're not.
Inherently what you're seeing with white
people is human beings with unchecked
power. The result of that, okay,
so what you would then see is if
another group where to get that power,
they would behave in the exact same way.
And what I would say
is the me too movement.
Okay?
If you look at how these powerless women
then handled the power of being able to
destroy,
you know,
first of all get get people who did
something wrong all and then how quickly
that spun out of fucking
control to just like, um,
I was in a toxic relationship,
which who the fuck hasn't been
okay?
Who the fuck can't look on back on
their dating history gonna be like,
Jesus Christ, I should have got out of
that relationship fucking two dates in.
Okay.
And then we would have avoided all of
that fucking drama of screaming and
yelling show,
but that me too.
Shit went from like these fucking horrible
guys that were taking their dicks out
and doing all this fucking horrible shit.
MMM.
To then just like he yelled
at me, you know, and, and,
and you just saw how bad that whole
fucking thing has spun out of control.
I thought, uh, how, uh, I don't want
to fucking stir up the name here again.
How a certain fucking group prevented a
certain fucking performer from doing a
dream Gig this year. I thought that their
unchecked power that they went from,
despite the fact that they became,
uh, an entity to protect victims,
they actually became the bullying that
point where this person had already
fucking apologize.
So there needs to be more of that.
Okay.
Because the ultimate goal is to get white
people to understand the position of
somebody who isn't white. So when
you come at people that way, that's,
that's how it's done on the
Internet in a more crass way,
which I've always said is when
somebody is presenting an opinion,
there'll be like a hey fuck head, maybe if
you fucking blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
They start with hey fuck,
like who's listening after that?
MMM.
So,
and it's weird cause I unders cause I
though it's one of the first huge fights I
got in with Patrice O'neil when he said
it was impossible for black people to be
ready. I was like, what the, what the
fuck are you talking about? And uh,
and then I later found out he was quoting
like spike Lee and it wasn't even his
quote.
Um,
yeah,
but that whole, that whole thing where
that woman came over to me and if she,
if she came home and said, you two look
like you don't want to be here, uh,
you got to go right back
at a person like that.
You two look like you don't want
to be here. And I would be like,
and I would just look at it. I
go, what? What is that based on?
And I would throw it right back at her.
So now you're coming over
here judging me and my vibe.
Okay.
And your comment over here with like
this aggressive thing. What this,
this veiled sort of,
I'm going to report you cause you weren't
sitting here with the big smile on
your face.
What do you want me to do now?
Be Reversed Louie Armstrong
while I listen to this shit.
Is that what I'm supposed to fucking do?
You told me to do this and I did.
This is the thing like,
but you're not allowed to say that in
that it's like well you kind of came the
whole fucking way you entered
this was not the way that,
that's just not the fucking way to do it.
You know?
And then if somebody is up
there while they're doing that,
also trying to sell books,
the whole thing is fucking hilarious.
You two look like you don't
want to be here. Oh I'm sorry.
I was thinking about where the nearest
Barnes and noble was so I could go out
and buy your book.
Yeah.
Do you have any sort of guilt that you're
trying to make money off of this? Um,
yeah. So here's the thing I see, I
see both sides of that. Like, like
white people challenging racism.
That's a weird title for what happened.
MMM.
I thought that that was going to be like,
you know,
when white people do that thing,
when somebody,
a black person talks about racism and
they go like slavery was like 180 years
ago. Fagging get over it.
Like they do that shit.
Like I've thought that that's what
this email was going to be about. Um,
which obviously is
astoundingly ignorant and uh,
it didn't affect so many people's lives.
That would be actually funny on
some fucking level. Um, yeah,
so that's my take on that.
So if anybody does that,
like the big thing about when you're
presenting an opinion and God knows I
learned this by doing
it the wrong way for,
for fucking 40 of my 50 years is you
have to enter your point in a way that
keeps the other people's deflector
shields down so they can hear what you're
saying.
And then also feel that you're not saying
that they are the thing that you're
talking about.
MMM.
That would be my suggestion.
And um, when you're doing that,
you know,
yeah,
I dunno. I that fucking lady,
they're just sitting there
sitting that going, cause
I got a black husband. Um,
I've written a black Dick,
so I feel like I should be here.
Um,
we need a white person that's halfway
into the black world here to maybe help
the white people that are fully in the
white world to bridge the gap between
themselves and then this African
American woman here who's going to try to
inform them while selling
books. Um, all right.
Titanic theory. All right. Hey,
bill a, they are Billy false flag.
Uh, do you know the theory
behind the titanic sinking? Uh,
in short,
JP Morgan owned the titanic and the
Olympic completely identical ships.
Olympic was damaged in port before it
could be insured according to a shipyard
captain. At the time Morgan had
all the identification changed.
So it said titanic on the, now we, we can
Olympic get the fuck outta here.
Morgan was supposed to be on the
ship but fell ill at the last minute.
Important side note,
this was all while Morgan was fighting
for a central banking system so he can
manipulate us markets even more.
Also the voyage on the voyage where two
billionaires who opposed the federal
system and stood in Morgan's way.
There's a lot of good info on this one.
Billy would love to hear your thoughts.
I love to read about it.
What you're basically doing here
is you're presenting motive,
all right? Where he would definitely
have a motive if all of that is true,
but how do you prove the old switcheroo,
which is what a lot of
conspiracy theory starts off with in a
reminds me of this great Robert Klein
joke. When he was making fun of those
people at late night, they would tell you,
uh, how to get rich and he would
start it off. He goes, okay,
you have no money. So you buy a house and
then you take the equity in the house.
She don't own in like, it all starts off
with this giant leap of bullshit. Like,
wait a minute, I don't have any
money. How do I buy a house?
Um, how do you PR, how do you prove to me
the Olympic was damaged in port
before it could be insured?
I mean,
how bad was it damaged
though? I don't believe
this. I don't believe it.
I, yeah, I, I simply don't believe that.
So what had already had holes in it
and then they just sent it out. I know.
I don't believe that.
Um,
and also I think the people, the way
the exam of the boat when they found it,
I didn't everything kind
of fall in place. I, yeah,
I don't believe that the old me would've
believed that damn bed and we meet from
10 years ago would've believed that.
Um, but I'll, I'll look it up. That's,
that's fascinating shit. That
makes for a great, I'll take it.
Makes for a great fucking movie.
All right.
High School's Sweetie reached
out to me. Oh Jesus. Dear bill,
longtime listener of the podcast,
seen all your specials.
Look forward to season Pfoa
of FC for F is for family.
I am 22 and I've been listening to
the podcast for the last five years.
Tremendous. Uh, the other day
I literally put myself in, in,
I put you in my shoes.
Like all of a sudden if you were 50 in
your high school sweetheart reached out
to you.
How weird that would be.
Cause both of you would be married or
divorced and would be crazy. Um, anyways,
I am 22 and I've been listening to
the podcast for the last five years.
The other day,
my high school sweet.
He texted me out of the blue explaining
that I was on her mind and she couldn't
hold back or feelings of curiosity.
So she texted me. Well that was smart.
It's what she should though. You're young.
This is all, this is all above board? No,
no biting, no Biden.
Um, they'll side book.
I now live in a different city,
have a new girlfriend and my ex and
I haven't spoken in over a year.
Okay.
Oh,
so you only broke up with her a year ago?
I thought you haven't talked to her
since high school. Oh, okay. In the past.
She has reached out to me when she's
having difficulties in her current
relationship and in my opinion,
would text me to test the waters to see
if I was ready to get back together with
her. And of course, things would
always escalate to the bedroom.
Her texts went on to say that the next
time I was in town we should get together
for coffee or something
and quote, catch up. Uh,
I was skeptical, but played
along and agreed. What?
You have a new girlfriend here, man, I
don't know about this, but you're young.
This is what you do. I was skeptical
what played along and agreed.
She then went on to say that she has the
cutest puppy and I just have to meet.
All right now she's drawn you into her
house or apartment and I was even more
skeptical of her true intentions.
Jesus career acting like the white
guy in every fucking the horror movie.
When I was growing up,
I need to investigate.
I asked her if she still lived
with her current boyfriend.
Okay.
And she said, no, it's complicated.
Okay,
so bill,
would I just be dumb to actually meet up
with her and chat with the thought that
maybe she actually wants to catch up or
should I just stay away reaching out to
you because you've always been
great with advice or relationship,
which wish you and your family
all the best. All right,
let me get to the top of this thing here.
Um, I now live in a different city
and have a new girlfriend. All right.
You have a girlfriend, dude, so you
should know you should not be doing this.
Would you be cool if your new girlfriend
was fucking catching up with her old
boyfriend who got a new goldfish and
wanted her to come by his apartment to
check it out?
You know what she wants to do?
I know my listeners know and you know,
your deck is taking you over there,
buddy. You don't seem like you,
you didn't mention one time that you
still have feelings for this woman at all.
Okay.
I think it's some fucking throwback
pussy that you're going to. Uh,
it's not fair to your new girlfriend.
You shouldn't fucking do it unless you
still have feelings for this woman.
At which point you should not be in
a relationship with this other new
girlfriend.
He should figure that out.
But all is forgiven because you're
only 22 years old, you know,
and you have a dick.
So these are tough years as a guy.
You don't know what the fuck that though.
So no, I would not go. I, I would,
you know,
if I could go back and
talk to the 22 year old me,
I would say don't do shit
like this. Um, especially now.
Okay,
okay,
well you have social media and all that
and there's nothing preventing her after
you hook up with her, which
you know, you're gonna do.
There's nothing preventing her from
fucking, you know, when she finds a,
she know you have a girlfriend,
she probably doesn't.
And if she finds out there's the,
you know, you're going to get caught,
the whole fucking thing's going to
blow up and you face, you know, Eh,
then that's going to be yet. So I
would not do it. I wouldn't do it.
It's not fair to the girlfriend that
you have, but, um, I dunno, you,
the weird thing about all of this is I
don't think you're in to either one of
these women. I think you should be
single because you have a new girlfriend.
You didn't say that. I love, that's
fucking awesome and blah blah blah, blah.
He didn't say that. And then he didn't
say that. You still love your ex.
Um,
okay.
I think you're trying to fuck both
these checks is what I'm thinking.
I wouldn't do it.
And I would also try to assess how you
feel about your new girlfriend before you
waste her time and break her
heart. You might want to be
single. He's one. I'm, I'm,
I'm leaning towards that. I don't have
enough information here, but that's,
I didn't see any sort of, uh, you know,
my high school sweetheart.
I felt like I could be with her.
I thought this was the one,
I never heard that and I never heard that,
but the new one,
so I'm just going to keep saying
the same thing over and over again.
So good luck with dad situation, sir. Um,
it's tricky one. All right. That's
the podcast, everybody. I'm,
I'm going to watch the Moto GP and get
caught up and supports some sports and
try to catch the, uh, tiger woods masters
to at least some fucking highlights,
something of it. Uh, once again, Travis
roid tickets, foundation tickets,
go on sale.
Uh,
the presale is this freaking Wednesday
and Thursday. I'm going to tweet,
sorry, tweet the link, Instagram it
and all of that shit of Facebook it,
and, uh, please come down.
It's going to be a great, great
night. A stand up for, uh,
a great foundation and a,
that's it. Go fuck yourselves.
And I'll check in on, yeah,
on Thursday.